In the last section, we saw that our new
algorithm, based on the leaderboard and
“cut” method, worked well on a
spectrum that was close to the correct
theoretical spectrum.
But once we had 25% false and missing
masses, it didn't reconstruct the correct
Tyrocidine B1 peptide.
I want to add some more bad news to that
in this section, which is that these NRPs,
these non-ribosomal peptides,
including Tyrocidine B1,
in practice will contain more
non-standard amino acids
that are outside of the standard
genetic code.
And this is because they're outside of the
Central Dogma.
For example, here is a relative of
Tyrocidine B1 called Tyrocidine B.
And it's very similar to Tyrocidine B1
except you'll notice
that in this position, it has an amino
acid called ornithine.
This is a non-standard one.
And so to deal with these non-standard
amino acids, because there
are so many of them,
what bioinformaticians assume,
sometimes,
and what we'll assume here, is that any
integer between 57
and 200 can act as the mass of an amino
acid.
So we've expanded now our integer mass
alphabet, from
18 masses to 144 amino acids, by making
this assumption.
So then our question is, OK, we expand
our alphabet and
now we have to deal with a larger class of
peptides.
Let's run our LeaderboardCyclopeptideSequencing
algorithm on this expanded
alphabet.
To this Spectrum10, with 10% false and
missing masses.
Now remember that before, when we assumed the
standard alphabet,
it reconstructed Tyrocidine B1 correctly.
But here when we expand the alphabet out
to
144 amino acids, the algorithm now
identifies
the highest scoring peptide as this
peptide.
And it incorporates 98 and 65 into the
So it doesn't reconstruct the peptide
correctly,
and notice that it's brought in two
nonstandard amino acids.
The key point here is that although
Tyrocidine B1
doesn't actually contain any of these
nonstandard amino acids,
we won't know that when we're doing
sequencing experiments.
So we need to take them into account.
And in this case, the algorithm would tell
us that
it has nonstandard amino acids in it, and
that's not good,
because it doesn't.